Luke and Tom here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're gonna
find out what's inside a polished
aluminum foil ball it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
so guys if you've been following our
channel this week we have been having a
load of fun with these polished aluminum
foil balls now what we're doing is we're
taking a big wad of aluminum like this
and we're shaping it with hammers and
squishing it and pounding on it and
polishing and sanding it till it becomes
like this but we've been having a lot of
really great comments in our videos
about this and it seems like the number
one thing people want to see is what's
inside one of these aluminum foil balls
does it look like a solid piece of
aluminum is it all fluffy is there a
hollow goodness inside what does it look
like so we're gonna find out and we're
gonna cut them up one of the fun things
about this is we have different aluminum
foil balls we have this one right here
which is an entire roll of aluminum foil
that we beat excessively with a hammer
this small one right here though is
three rolls of aluminum foil
it's crazy dense so for those of you
watching this video with a keen eye you
may have noticed that I wet my pants
earlier today I was shooting a video
where I went through 12 liters of soda
in about five minutes and well accidents
happen especially when you're testing
out a hog splitter you just finished
that video I'll be posting it on
Saturday so don't forget to click
subscribe so you can get notified
remember we put out awesome videos like
this hogs splitter video and just to be
clear this is soda on my pants not urine
ok I want to start with this ball first
it's the first aluminum foil ball we
made and it is the most dense it's a
hundred and twenty square feet of
aluminum foil about three rolls and we
made it by taking a very small
compressed ball and then carefully
adding one flat layer of aluminum foil
after another
until we got this all right I'm gonna
use a coping saw because it's got the
really fine teeth on it so hopefully
it'll make a nice clean cross-section
for us to look at that is a lot more
solid than I thought it would be you can
kind of see that the layers if you pull
out a little bit
you'll exposes the layers a little bit I
want to get a better look at this I'm
gonna pull out my jeweler's eye and show
you what we got we were wondering how
getting these shots I'm literally taking
my jewelers eye holding it up to the
lens of my camera and then holding it
over the top of the aluminum foil ball
we'd like to check out the polished
surface of this aluminum foil ball under
jewelers eye let's give it a go
well cutting that aluminum ball in half
with a hacksaw was the intelligent and
scientific way of finding out what's
inside
aluminum foil balls but this is YouTube
where we do things that are dangerous
and unnecessary and with that in mind I
have a bearded axe in my hand and those
of you who follow my channel will
recognize this as the axe from my no
power tools bearded axe restoration
video check out the link up here or
check out the link in the description
we've got a ton of fun axe restoration
videos but I'm curious to see whether I
can split this sucker into using my
bearded axe hopefully it won't just
shoot off the stump and hit me in the
nards and well be good views if it does
but alright here goes nothing I thought
I just nicked it but I don't think
that's true I think I hit it right here
and the blade just slid off look at that
that is cool let's try it again
[Music]
Wow that's awesome yeah that was a clean
hit look at that look at that
oh whoa that is in there deep oh wow
that actually put a nick in my ax look
at that I think we need to try a
different tool
[Applause]
well there you go
that's what it looks like now this ball
is interesting because if you remember
from our video we just took an entire
roll of aluminum foil crumpled it up
with their hands and then beat it a
bunch with the hammer to make this ball
and so you can see the inside is not
that compacted there's a lot of spaces
and voids in the center and then on the
outside it looks super compacted alright
let's check it out with the jewelers I
you can see here in the middle these big
void and as we get out to the outside it
looks a lot more compacted oh yeah there
well guys that was a lot of fun thanks
for all the great comments and
suggestions now if you're wondering what
am I gonna do with this one
well the outdoor boy's youtube channel
is about to hit 100,000 subscribers and
I was thinking maybe to celebrate that I
might make aluminum play button if you
think that's a good idea
smash that like button let me know leave
a comment or if you have a better idea
of what you think I should be doing to
celebrate 100,000 subscribers let me
know one comment that's come up over and
over again is the idea that I could get
sick from aluminum exposure often people
would say I would get Alzheimer's
disease or as some people said
old-timers disease this is something
that's been floating around the internet
for a while so I strongly suggest if
you're concerned about this or if you
want to know more about this go to the
CDC's website I'll put a link in the
description we have an entire page
dedicated to issues regarding the
toxicity of aluminum and the general
takeaway is you don't want to breathe in
metal shavings or metal dust the other
takeaway is that there isn't really any
strong evidence to suggest that dementia
or Alzheimer's disease is linked to
luminol exposure a couple days ago I
posted a video about trying to polish an
aluminum foil ball in a microwave it's a
really fun goofy video if you haven't
seen it but in that video you guys saw
my wife walking with a cane and a lot of
people had some questions about that if
you'd like to know more about what's up
with that check out this video I also
put a link in the description thanks for
watching guys we hope you enjoyed this
video make sure to click Subscribe
because we have some great videos coming
up soon I've got that hog splitter
restoration video coming up this
Saturday additionally I'm working on
restoring a Bulgarian bearded axe that's
just amazing and I'm gonna be doing a
tutorial on how to catch and trap
toddlers it's going to be very
entertaining and the weather is getting
warmer so we've got some awesome camping
videos we're planning as well thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more
great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video